Nhận thấy tình trả sức quay của người phụ nữa có dịch biển viên hình cần được cấp kiểu trong thời gian sớm nhất
Tổ cũng tắc lập tức dừng phương tiện tiếp gần phố chở sự kiểu bản đầu
Đông thời gian trong đường người bệnh đến câu sợ ý tệ gần nhất để được kiểm tra cấp kiểu
Trong có chính dí truyền, cả bộ trên sĩ tổ cũng tắc của hợp bảo đảm ảm tỏa thông
Tại được kiện thật lời để người bệnh được cấp kiểu kiểu kiểu thời
Còn xâm yên bản đầu người phụ nữa là bà giứng thì tải xinh năm 2019
Tại trụ tại xả buồn đang tình đồng này sau khi được xơ kiểu tại cơ sở ý tế
Nhận thấy cần tiếp tục điều chỉ chuyến sâu, tổ cũng tắc lạ nhắn trong vũ trở
Đưa bà giương thi tài để bệnh viện tình đắc năm 2019
Nể các ý bà sĩ tham khảm các cấp kiểu, hành động kiệt thời của cản bộ
Chính sĩ tổ cảnh sức tổ thông đường bộ xu ba
Không chỉ có phần giúp người dân có cơ hội được cấp kiểu sớm trong tình trạng quyết mạc còn thế hiện
Tình thần trách nhiệp sự tất truy true đậu vũ trở nhắn dân trong quá trình thật hiện nhẹn bộ
Này là một trong những việc làm thiết thử trong thực hiện phong trào thi đua bà nhất
Vồn kỳ lật nhất, chúng ta nhất, gần dân nhất của cảnh sâu thông công wan tỷ lắm đông
Có phần lan toả hình ảnh đẹp của người trên sĩ cảnh sâu thông
Vì nhân dật phục bộ, đường sợ sàng hỗ trợ giúp đậu người dân thi gặp có khăn, quán nạn trên các tình đường